you describe your dad as sort of this
guy
drugs uh everything everything
everything you name it if it was bad my
dad did it you know from drugs to jail
addictions i mean he he had a rough a
rough bout with life did your dad ever
try to like discipline you and punish
you for bad things you did or is he just
like [ __ ] it i can't say it no like he
couldn't lecture you my dad was the
coolest dad ever man you know he was a
guy that that he it was it was a bad
kind of cool he was the guy that would
hey dad is it okay if we go take that
fire hydrant apart so we can clear the
water go ahead
hey dad hey dad can we get in the car
and play with the uh play with the
steering wheel go ahead just come back
in there when you're done well don't you
tell a story i forget how old you were
you were like a little kid and your dad
puts you in the car to drive or
something
he let me drive a boat yeah i crashed
the boat and he acted like it was no big
deal first of all the the level of
stupidity that my dad displayed this day
was was amazing he's it was a speed boat
and i asked my dad can i drive the boat
where did he even get a speed boat he
borrowed the boat he burned borrowed the
boat from a friend so the friend rented
the boat he borrowed the boat from the
friend that rented the boat so nobody
has any ownership of this boat so we
take the boat out because we were going
fishing and my dad drove it out and
coming back i was like dad can i drive
the boat he was like go ahead so
basically how old are you like nine
i'm like nine years old so he's like go
ahead
and i remember pulling this thing and my
dad kept going slow up and i i don't
know how to slow up how do i do that
what kid you know slows up all we know
is fast and my dad start going hey kev
yeah i'm serious slow up and we're
getting closer and as we're getting
closer to this thing this is where my
dad should have moved me taken over the
thing and
maneuvered it so we would be okay
instead he literally let me run into we
ran into like this rock bay we ran into
the bay we tore the boat up and i
remember my dad telling the guy he was
like we're gonna have to figure this out
the guy was like what's that really out
what's wrong with you you crashed the
boat he's like look let's just talk
later we'll figure it out we never saw
that guy oh my god
he was in constant trouble yeah
and even someone was nice to him lent
him the boat so he go fishing with his
sons we got to figure it out and that we
yeah
man we go we'll figure it out call me
later we can figure it out in the van we
went home